yesterday was a wild day in the
financial markets literally insane asset
prices going down and then coming
roaring back at the end of the day to
end up actually being positive what the
hell is going on the federal reserve is
meeting today and tomorrow and they are
going to have a lot to talk about
inflation is hitting 40-year highs
unemployment coming down everyone is
worried about what the hell they're
gonna do with interest rates and of
course we are heading into the midterm
election season so the federal reserve's
got a lot to figure out but just because
they've been talking about raising
interest rates asset prices have been in
a free fall we've seen bitcoin trade off
50 we've seen stocks trade down
significantly as well but yesterday
right at the close of the market asset
prices had a little relief rally i
jokingly tweeted and said well that was
a short bear market i'm joking nobody
knows what's going to happen in the
future but here you can see bitcoin come
raging back at the end of the day on top
of that the last two months in the stock
market has been real bad but here's the
dow jones industrial there we go ladies
and gentlemen right around 1 p.m the
plunge protection team coming into the
market and let's boost it up a little
bit let's get back up to a little bit
better pricing right before that federal
reserve meeting and then of course if we
look at the s p 500 and the dow what you
can see is the exact same thing right
around one o'clock bam let's get back to
zero let's finish the day positive now
why the hell is all this volatility in
markets happening well there's a number
of different things that are actually
occurring first is that the interest
rate hikes could potentially be
occurring we need to know what the hell
is going on with those interest rates on
top of that the fed will meet today and
tomorrow to chart that monetary policy
then there's been the earnings reports
there's been a mixed reaction some of
them are good some of them are bad some
consumer demand is persistent some of it
is not and then of course there's a
bunch of earnings that are on the
horizon apple ibm intel microsoft and
then of course
joe biden in the current administration
we're going to go to war with russia
they're going to prevent them from
invading ukraine right i don't know but
world war iii is literally trending on
twitter i got no clue what's going on on
the geopolitical landscape all i know is
that when there is uncertainty when
there's doubt when there is fear when
there is concern in the market there is
volatility prices and assets go up they
go down they go sideways nobody knows
what's gonna happen there's just massive
freaking chaos what do you guys think
i think uh it's interesting because this
isn't how bitcoin moved previously right
when you think about uh 2017 2018 and
things ratcheted up real quick price
wise and then went way down into a
winner for a couple of years it didn't
move in tandem with the rest of the
market at least risk assets and now what
we're seeing is that it is moving in
tandem with risk asset at risk assets
it's having uh an impact from the
federal reserve's decision stocks are
selling off bitcoin is selling off in
tandem and i think what we're seeing is
now there's much more institutional
capital at play this is a much uh much
more is much more of an asset that is
allocated from an institutional
perspective and i don't think we're ever
going to see those four-year bear
markets again to be honest i think that
this has become much more mainstream
than people realize and ultimately it's
going to start moving maybe more in line
with traditional markets right there was
just no reason previously as to why sure
the having and all these other things
but ultimately from a macro standpoint
there wasn't really a huge reason in the
financial markets as to why bitcoin did
that before and now it has a little more
kind of common sense around it and look
you can say everyone's like hey everyone
no one knows why this stuff is falling
it's very clear it's a risk asset it's
being treated as such from with
institutional capital they are selling
to move into safer things with the
expectation that the fed is going to
hike rates ultimately that supply and
demand and balance is what drops the
price and what we're going to see is
it's going to be a tug of war right with
the fed what ends up happening and to
your point like do they want high
inflation in an election year no do they
want the stock market to fall in the
election year no they're in a very tough
place because if they start hiking rates
too fast and the stock market and
bitcoin and all these other assets
continue to sell off there's gonna be a
big problem people are gonna riot right
like everyone wants to see their 401ks
go up everyone wants to see their
savings account goes up everyone wants
to see their bank account go up right
and i think ultimately uh that's when
kind of the the euphoria is that it's at
its peak with the government and
ultimately if they start raising rates
too fast and too quickly all of that's
going to going to collapse and what
we're going to see is people get
frustrated very quickly john what do you
think this shows to me that the bitcoin
market has matured over the last few
years right in its correlation to stocks
the fact that everything roared on the
second half of the day really just means
that the fed's decision in my mind was
already priced into the markets the
people that move the markets are really
the institutions that bring a lot of
capital it can actually move the market
versus just the average retail trader so
this is kind of expected a little bit i
don't think anyone expected the severity
of the volatility yesterday going s p
going down three percent bitcoin drawing
down as well um but everything ended up
yesterday right so does it really matter
and look if you have a long time horizon
i'll say this again and again but if you
have a long time horizon that you don't
worry about these small um
intraday moves if you're not day trading
the asset so i think bitcoin is becoming
more mature as an asset and i think
we're going to see that going forward
and we're going to kind of break this
cycle i think of the having and bear and
bull i market i don't think too to to
your point from the other day like i
don't think people are placing enough uh
substance in the fact that politics
matter in all of this right like what do
you mean
joe biden president biden doesn't want
to have the stock market collapsing
right that is not good for him inflation
running hot is not good for him right he
needs to get the economy in a better
place and although the federal reserve
and his office are supposed to be
completely separate you know who his
boss is right jerome powell's boss right
like ultimately uh they are not
separated they may be from like a a
optical illusion standpoint uh but
ultimately they have a lot of influence
on each other so i think joe biden is
going to look at this and say hey look i
don't want uh i don't want to hike rates
too fast because then the stock market
is going to crash people are going to be
upset people were already coming out of
a pandemic right and that's what they
printed so much money that inflation ran
so hot and ultimately now they're in a
really hard spot because they can't do
either of those two without impacting
the other right if they hike rates 50
basis points next meeting the stock
market's going to tank and people are
going to be upset if they don't do
anything then inflation continues to run
hot the stock market will stay and
bitcoin will continue to rise but
ultimately inflation you can't keep it
at seven percent year over year it's a
lose-lose situation right i think that's
what a lot of people uh aren't quite uh
up to speed on that was a much more
concise way to say yeah well
literally you let inflation run hot
everyone's freaking out right you go
into midterm elections you probably
literally get your entire political
party everyone who's uh got a challenger
see you you're out you're fired right if
you could uh actually step in and you
get inflation down but also everyone's
looking at their portfolio and they're
like holy [ __ ] i'm i'm literally losing
money i'm bleeding out assets people
were like dude get these people the hell
out of here right and so uh it's a it's
a tightrope walk i think it's the right
way to think about this is you want to
ease just enough and ultimately one of
the things that may occur again we don't
know what's going to happen in this uh
fed meeting this week but one of the
things they may do is they may talk
tough but not actually take action and
so therefore the talking tough ends up
bringing the markets down a little bit
and trying to curb some of that
inflation but ultimately they don't have
to raise interest rates a ton in the
first half of the year which then
crashes the stock market sends us into a
recession like the worst case scenario
would actually be an over rotation back
into a recession because you're trying
to curb inflation right the only thing
worse than high inflation is a recession
and so you got to be careful here of
like you know you almost have to choose
between the lesser of two evils and so
running a little bit hotter if you can
get inflation down to maybe four percent
but you don't actually force an uh a
complete crash in stock market you don't
force a complete uh recession then like
you may just say hey look this is the
best that we can do let's try to get
that soft landing now as we know though
you know you're basically dealing with a
complex machine with all these different
inputs you pull on one thing pulling on
another you don't necessarily know
exactly what the intended impact is
going to be and so you know i don't envy
being in any of these people's positions
i don't envy being in the politicians
position rnv being in the uh the central
bankers position because i don't think
that there's one single right answer
it's basically everyone's kind of trying
to figure it out as they go and so it's
a tough job and guess what us and
everyone else is just going to rail
against whatever decision they make
anyways they're like this is stupid it
didn't have the intended impact which
you know probably is unfair but at the
same time that's how the world works